[inaudible]
the tank.
So Gilbert,
the thing,
anybody could use the tag.
It's Bilbo,
right?
Can you think Brian?
Yeah.
You're ready for you?
You relax in there.
You know the whole deal behind it.
Oh yeah.
You float on salt water.
You see Jesus.
Good Bill.
Get in it.
We're just gonna.
I'm gonna start getting this,
this fucking box.
We're going to start filling it up with water.
Silver.
We would love to have you on the podcast.
Do a podcast blog to me and Brian made up.
We already made up ever the c level couple of fist bumps.
Lotion.
It was fun though.
You're going to get trolled hard now though.
You realize that,
right?
The Internet,
those fucking kids.
First of all,
I don't read like I even got it.
Does it?
You don't read your emails?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's why it's this or probably just contact the a thousand times
they're trying to take pill away from me still.
If they contacted me,
I never said that they could take it.
Jeez.
Can RSSP right Brian,
tell them about the second you take your car in the driveway.
I mean,
right there.
That's your fault.
If you put it in a parking lot and somebody steals it,
show me.
How are you Jimmy?
How are you?
Are you excited
when you think about tonight buddy?
Ah,
I want to,
I don't want to give my pick because every time John,
every time I pick every one I picked,
I kind of don't want to jinx him.
Like what do you think should fear?
John Jones very confidently says this.
Yeah,
I like John Zone.
That's why I wanted to win.
I'm like the guy in what's happening.
Who was picking the off then?
It wouldn't be run was picking the teams based on their helmets.
I don't remember what's happening at Wayne.
Good reference though for 2011.
And what's happening?
What was that?
1997 what's happening now?
What's happening now?
What is that?
That was the remake of what's happening.
And that was the guy that was the,
uh,
the second helping of it.
Yeah.
What was,
what happened was that it was all the early eighties,
right?
Yeah,
they do.
And I are old and we're just starting to give out.
How old do you know?
42 got Sam.
43 yeah.
Oldest.
How old are you?
37 37 you're still holding onto his thirties.
You still got a strong three years to go by.
What a non uncomfortable camera person am.
I am actually looking into the lens like a fucking retard.
I'm looking at you though.
We Miss John Ona yesterday.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I was going up picking Boston.
Brian.
Yeah.
I had to go from Florida to Boston through the Wilberg probably rather have been
studio.
It was fine.
Yeah.
I know you shop and came in through,
what was he promoting was even more than that thing in the village for teller.
Yeah.
Teller will come on.
I actually got voicemail.
Some tellers.
I want to play them on the yard so bad,
but I can't cause us any.
My I leaving and he's like,
hey man,
you think he was inviting me to the show?
It's actually good.
And I'm like,
I can't,
I can't play it on the uh,
on the salads because he doesn't talk.
He did a fear factor.
You didn't talk to him the whole show,
but he talked in between takes.
It was kind of weird.
Yeah.
It was like,
and then we would do the show and nothing.
Yeah.
You know?
But that's a perfect kid from had you locked up because he loves the APP.
Yeah.
He's a good talker.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
Yeah.
It's a balance.
What are you think of that?
I don't have any fucking idea.
Shoguns and killer man.
You know a lot of people are selling them short.
Shoguns got a lot of fucking experience,
man.
He's an assassin.
He's a cold blooded motherfucker.
He's not.
He's going to find openings.
The thing is,
John Jones is a super talent man.
He's like a Michael Jordan type character.
They're just unbelievably physically gifted.
Who knows,
man.
That's what makes it exciting.
My theory is that Joe Rogan always talk about the guy.
He doesn't think he's going to win a lot more because he's got a chance.
Who wants to make sure everyone knows about those chances?
And you've been talking nonstop about about Shogun and how much of a killer,
you know,
how dare you,
how dare you find my strategy for commentating.
Okay.
How come?
Freaked out.
Freaked out with these guys.
Be If I just have to know and utilize models.
They do it like it all Shogun seem right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
they,
they get creeped out when want to do it right now on film.
It wouldn't translate.
My fucking teeth are trickling down the floor.
The first fight is about the star.
It is a right now like five minutes to seven.
We're very excited.
This is,
yeah,
arena before it all starts.
What's up dude?
Sit down.
I'm good.
What's up man?
Where you guys
go?
Boards in the motherfucking on Logan.
What's up?
What's up
Brian?
Nine Ladies and gentlemen.
Ryan Deiss say,
what can I say?
Joe Rogan.
30 seconds before we go first fight.
My Goldberg.
Ready?
30 seconds.
Here we go.
Are you excited?
I am excited to go see baby.
Yes.
Jon Jones.
Shogun.
So you get a nice taboo from the black guy.
Oh,
what up badly.
Joe,
what's up,
brother?
Right
then in the evening or the light heavyweight title?
No.
Okay.